when you think of a sculpture you
probably imagine one of these
would you ever imagine something that
can fit in the eye of a needle huh
meet Willard Wigan I'm Dr Willard wiggin
MBE I make the smallest sculptures in
the world
I've made 14 camels in the oven needle
the Queen's carriage and I've made one
of the queen herself Mount Rushmore
sunshique evolution of man Marianne
twinette Little Red Riding Hood Einstein
and more I'd be here forever trying to
tell you that I've done that many you
know it all began with an ant's Nest I
thought the answer homeless
so I started making them tables and
chairs
started picking up little fragments of
splinters and slicing them and
constructing and building little houses
I'm autistic and in school they didn't
really care I call it a learning
difference I just learn different to
anybody else I started experimenting to
see how small I could really go
how do you make something so beautiful
when I'm working on a microscopic level
have to work between my heartbeat
because if I don't the pulse in my
finger will cause problems but the tools
are very important because they all vary
in all different types of tools The
Cutting is the most important thing
slicing and twisting and bending and
manipulating I use a little broken Shard
of diamond smashed and it's like a
little Splinter looks like a stone age
splint being microscopic so it's like my
pulse is a little Jackhammer chiseling
away
till I get get the shape I want
I normally pluck an eyelash out from the
corner of my eye I'm going to attach it
to a little cocktail stick and then I
paint with it I work on five at a time
if I work on one it'll drive me mad
[Music]
I have two World Records the smallest
sculptures never made by human hands not
no machine no nanotechnology
but these micro sculptures don't always
go to plan I remember once I was making
a sculpture of Alice in Wonderland after
I'd made the mad at her and I made the
teapot I made Alice separately and I was
lifting there put it into the needle and
my mobile phone went off
I went like this who's that and I
inhaled Alice it's just when she's in my
cavity somewhere gone
yeah the work that I do it doesn't
belong to me I like other people seeing
it I like to sit there and watch them
some people burst into tears when they
see my work you know and that brings it
home to me when I've done the time that
I've put in has been worth it so what
next for Willard I know he's stuck in
the needle yeah that's a good one
I'm gonna do that you know